[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
and there you have it the band of the
welsh guards playing the u.s national
anthem as they commemorate the 9 11
attacks 20 years after they happened at
windsor castle this is the daily
changing of the guard where the old and
new guard at windsor castle changes the
first battalion the cold scream cold
stream guards excuse me and watching on
there is the acting u.s ambassador
philip
t rico
fair ambassador philip tirica he's the
acting u.s ambassador
well the prime minister boris johnson
has released a statement to mark the
anniversary of the attacks which killed
67 british people
a handful of dates are etched into our
collective memory some joyous
others tragic
20 years ago september 11 2001 became
in president roosevelt's words after
pearl harbor
a date which will live
in infamy
on a crystal clear morning terrorists
attacked the united states with the
simple goal of killing or maiming as
many human beings as possible
and by inflicting such bloodshed in the
world's greatest democracy they tried to
destroy the faith
of free peoples everywhere
in the open societies which terrorists
despise
and which we cherish
and it's precisely because of the
openness and tolerance of the united
states
the people of almost every nationality
and religion
were among the 2977
murdered on that day including
67 britons
each of them a symbol of the eternal
friendship between the united kingdom
and the united states
but while the terrorists impose their
burden
of grief and suffering and while the
threat
persists today
we can now say with a perspective of 20
years
that they failed
to shake our belief in freedom
and democracy they failed to drive our
nations apart
or to cause us to abandon our values or
to live in permanent fear
the fact
that we are coming together today
in sorrow but also in faith and resolve
demonstrates the failure of terrorism
and the strength of the bonds between us
i congratulate since 911 on their vital
work to educate young people about what
happened on that day
and in that spirit the united kingdom
promised our american friends
that we would be proud to receive a
memorial
forged from the twisted steel
of ground zero
and display it permanently in the
olympic park in london
which symbolizes freedom
and openness the exact reverse
of what the killer stood for
recent events in afghanistan only
strengthen our determination to remember
those who are taken from us
cherish the survivors and those who
still grieve
and hold fast to our belief
in liberty
and democracy
which will always prevail
over every foe
you